us-backed Iraqi forces say they've taken
an iconic mosque in the heart of Mosul
that was destroyed by Isis its recapture
comes three years to the day after Isis
declared its so-called Caliphate leader
Abu Bakr al Baghdadi later spoke from
the pulpit of the mosque the landmark
was heavily damaged by Isis a week ago
the extremist group is also facing
setbacks in Raqqa its stronghold in
Syria Holly Williams is in northern
Syria where she met with the American
commander in the fight against Isis in
Syria and in Iraq Holly good morning
good morning lieutenant general Steven
Townsend is the commander of the us-led
new us-led coalition to fight Isis and
we met with him yesterday at a US
military logistics base here in northern
Syria general Townsend came straight
from a forward command post near Raqqa
the city Isis calls its capital where US
backed fighters launched an assault this
month
assisted by American airstrikes I think
we're in actually the first 25 or 30
percent of the campaign for rocket we're
just getting started good in Raqqa
American troops have been welcomed in
this corner of Syria this logistics base
it's airstrip carved out of the desert
has storage space for over a hundred
tons of munitions but a surge this year
in civilian casualties caused by US
airstrikes bringing the official total
to around 500 deaths has drawn criticism
is the u.s. coalition doing something
differently in the way that it carries
out airstrikes no we're not you're
seeing a convergence of the fight in
Mosul and Raqqa a condensing of the
fight into a very small space and you
have armies slugging out with high
explosives in close quarters as US
backed fighters hones in on Isis from
the north
they've also clashed with Syrian regime
force
moving up from the south the u.s. shot
down a Syrian regime jet this month
after it dropped bombs new us-backed
forces we're not here to fight the
Syrian regime we're not here to fight
the Russians we're not here to fight the
Iranians we're here to fight Isis but we
will defend our forces against anyone
who threatens it general Townsend told
us that the US has now agreed a
demarcation line with the regime and its
ally Russia he downplayed fears that the
US and Russia could be drawn into a
direct conflict here Noora incredible
reporting Holly Williams in northern
Syria thank you so much